President Trump has been holding
televised press briefings every day now
we all see that but here's the strange
thing he's even bragged about the great
ratings he's getting and here's the
thing these days many many more people
are watching TV because they're not
allowed to leave their houses so it's
not that big a deal to get big ratings
these days in fact I couldn't believe
some of the stuff on other channels it's
actually been beating Trump in the
ratings for example the Food Network
beat Trump in the ratings with this
three-hour loop of that lunch time on
diners drive-ins and dives when Guy
Fieri ate a salad Animal Planet got
better ratings than Trump with a special
called shy stingrays
the sci-fi channel beat Trump in the
ratings with a 10-hour marathon of the
bouncing DVD logos screensaver Country
Music Television got better ratings than
Trump when they aired clip art of people
waving from tractors set to patriotic
country music
Bravo beat Trump's ratings with their
new reality show fabulously de spiders
and finally the e-channel Barry Trump in
the ratings with a special called least
googled celebrity feet
[Music]
okay so let's try and keep these things
in perspective shall we